تشيب كوكو جيد لرؤيتك مرة أخرى ، كيف
حالك جيد جدًا ، من فضلك مرحبًا بك في القاعدة
، يسعدني حقًا أن أرحب بكم هنا ، إنها
رائحته رائعة بالطبع إنها فوضى
إفريقيا ، المكان
كله يتعلق بالطعام الأفريقي ، إنه جناح
حيث نتواصل مع
طهاة مختلفين للعرض
جمال القارة
، القاعدة تعني أنها الاسم الأصلي
لأفريقيا
،
كانت الطريقة التي سُميت بها إفريقيا
قبل الروماني أعتقد أن الجنرال أو الجندي
قرر ذلك حسنًا الآن لأن اسمي
أفريقي سيُطلق عليه اسم إفريقيا ،
لذا فإن القاعدة تسير بشكل أساسي  بالعودة
إلى الأصل الأصلي تمامًا لما
جعل إفريقيا إفريقيا على حق ،
لماذا افتتحت جناحًا لكشك طعامًا أفريقيًا
في إكسبو ، كيف حدث ذلك ،
حيث
قرر معرض دبي أنه يجب
أن يكون هناك شيء يتعلق بالطعام الأفريقي على ما
يرام وحقيقة أنه  كنت في قاعة
حيث سآتي وألتقي أيضًا بشيف أفريقي آخر
حسنًا ، كنت مثل هذا هو بالضبط
شعار
دبي 2020 الذي يربط العقول
ويخلق المستقبل  وربط
البطون بالضبط
كيف استجاب الناس
للطعام للتجربة هنا ، أنا مندهش حقًا
من الطريقة التي كنا مشغولين بها مثل كل
يوم تقريبًا في الخارج ، لذا فإن الناس
مهتمون حقًا بتعلم
شيء مثل هذا لم يتم فعله من قبل
في أي مكان في العالم
، قاعة طعام أفريقية ، مكرسة بالكامل
للأطعمة الأفريقية ، حسنًا ، دعنا نذهب
لأخذ مقعد ،
المعرض يدور حول عرضه حول
البلدان الإعلانية ،
كيف تعتقد أنه سيساعدك على
معرفة تسويق
عملك وطعامك.  لقد قمت بالرئيس
التنفيذي لمنتدى الرؤساء التنفيذيين الأفريقيين ، لقد فعلت ذلك
لشبكة قيادية أفريقية في المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي ،
لكن في الوقت الحالي لا يوجد شيء
أكبر من معرض
إكسبو في الوقت الحالي هو أكبر مسرح
في العالم ولا
يوجد شيء أكبر يحدث في
العالم في  لحظة من إكسبو لا شيء ،
شكراً جزيلاً لك على وقتك لقد كان
من دواعي سروري حقًا وأتطلع
إلى الترحيب بالعالم بأسره هنا
في القاعدة وفي كل مرة  أفتقد المنزل ،
سأحضر بعض الطعام هنا ،
فأنت أكثر من تحياتي الترحيبية